[Music]
how many people are buried down here
stay over there
[Music]
you're not got a lights are gonna see
road trip we're going
a grenade is no joke I mean I get the
idea darkness neutralizes his biggest
strength at close quarters favors do
right I mean you can't throw at your
name without killing me too but what if
he tries gasps you know we're some sort
of sedative agent way ahead of me gas
masks and night-vision very smart over
zip ties this must be for me what can I
ask you something would you actually
stop talking long enough for me to
answer how much do you know that anybody
tell you why they wanted to death got
cracked killed eight ops in a single
night and his spine that's what they
told you that's what he did
no no not exactly I was there the night
all those operatives were hit they've
been sent to kill him and me by Gemini
and not that it matters but his spotter
was shot in Virginia and the rest of
those men went down in Savannah Henry
can shoot long distance but he can't
shoot that long come on just think does
that make any sense to you so you
understand what I'm saying it doesn't
you know
stay right there
thank you you gotta like one of those
Jesus Henry
thanks for the tip on the grenade you
were talking to him the whole time yeah
you need to search somebody or you don't
but for the record I do not want to kill
you but I absolutely will if I have to
what did clay virus tell you about me
okay
let me tell you about him cuz I know mr.
Barris very well how'd he start you
hunting birds rabbit about 12 years old
moved you up to deer
I'm guessing 19 20 years old the first
time he ordered you to shoot a person
any of this bring the truth then he told
you to lean into your fear because you
were a warrior blessed with great gifts
to defend the weak but he couldn't stop
the noise the secret party you had
always felt a little different than
everybody else
part two felt like a weirdo you know mo
[ __ ] okay I know you inside out and
backwards you're allergic to bees you
hate cilantro always sneeze four times
everybody hates cilantro you're
meticulous thorough disciplined
relentless you love puzzles your chess
player right good too I bet
but you suffer from insomnia it mine
never lets you sleep and even when it
does it attacks you with nightmares I'm
talking about those three o'clock in the
morning somebody please save me kind of
nightmares
then there's the doubts and those are
the worst you hate them and you hate
yourself for having them they make you
feel weak a real soldier doesn't doubt
right the only time you ever truly feel
happy is when you're flat on your belly
about to squeeze a trigger and in that
moment the world makes perfect sense how
do you think I know all
[ __ ] how do you know anything look at me
dummy look at us 25 years ago your
father took my blood and he cloned me he
made you from me our DNA is identical
he's telling you the truth
shut up he chosen me because there's
never been anybody like me and he knew
one day I was gonna get old and then
you'd step in he's been lying to you the
whole time he told you you were an
orphan and of all the people in the
world to come after me why would he send
you because I'm the best you are
obviously not the best you're a hard-ass
head guess this was supposed to be your
birthday or something I had to die and
you had to do it as long as I was alive
somehow Clay's little experiment was
incomplete
that's the maniac you're pulling a
trigger for shut your mouth about him
you're just trying to rattle me I'm
trying to save you
what are you 23 still a virgin right
dinah being a relationship and connect
but terrified to let anybody near you
because what if somebody actually saw
who you are after they loved you so
everybody's just targets you're just a
weapon
[Music]
when I saw was like I was seeing her
ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled how'd he start you hunting birds
rabbit guessing 19 20 years old the
first time he ordered you to shoot a
person 25 years ago he took my blood
he made you from me
he's been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you you made a choice
to do this to me the whole point of this
thing was to give you all of Henry's
gifts without his pain I don't want to
shoot you
fine if I shoot you
Henry is this ever having you before
your own government trying to kill you
wow that's new everything that we've
worked for is a stake he has to die
he's your darkness you had to walk
through this on your own I love you
Junior
we created
you're the inspiration for all of us
when I just make a whole army full of
them why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
[Music]